ich bin halt leider ein schlichtes
eindimensional das gemüt und immer schon
für die zu lesen bevor ich überhaupt den
mund aufmache aber ich versuche im hdj
quali gut ja brauner bär richtig gutes
zeug
kennt ihr matrix geiler film man richtig
gut hat mir wirklich gut gefallen
ich bitte auf den kennst du mir hier im
mitte erklärt was an diesem lied ich
muss mich ist ein literarisch gehaltvoll
also ich finde musik ja ich finde das
wirklich großartig finde richtig gutes
zeug weil es einerseits diese
phrasenhaft lichkeit mit der wir uns
alle im alltag äußern und prädikate
vergeben
finde ich wunderbar ironisch zitiert und
zwar sehr genau und ist es auch noch
wahnsinnig gesellschaftskritisch die
unterströmung ja du weißt ja ich bin ich
achte immer auf die unterströmung rudi
unterströmung ist hier die der
übersättigung alle haben schon viel zu
viel
und trotzdem hätten sie immer noch nach
12 99 aber richtig gut musste richtig
lange suchen für das ist doch super
[Musik]
ich finde ist es ein bisschen
eindimensional in der aussage muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen metaphorisch ist da
gar nichts heißt also verstehst du meine
begeisterung
ich finde das ist wirklich großartig
abgehört von dem was man auf der straße
hört aber trotzdem für diesen text
bekommt man kein literatur nobelpreis
ich finde es ist eine poetische gesetzte
sprache die nur auf den ersten blick so
umgangssprachlich wird das kostet
wirklich blut schweiß und tränen das ist
richtig gutes zeug ich finde ehrlich
gesagt diesen songtext als songtext
lustig ohne musik ist es mir zu wenig da
kannst du noch ein geschäft kritik wirst
jetzt handgreiflich und ja wenn worte
versagen
natürlich die kunst